[Applause]
[Music]
the Balkan Peninsula is a region with 12
countries that have just one thing in
common
NASA they all hate each other for
decades most of these countries were a
big part of a federation called
Yugoslavia which had a socialist system
very similar to that of the Soviet Union
after the fall of communism the
Yugoslavian estate broke apart and all
the regions separated from each other in
the most violent way possible if you're
about my age or slightly older you might
remember the terrible Balkan wars a
showcase of the worst part of the human
condition and all of this happens just a
few kilometers away from Italy and from
Greece so while the rest of Europe
enjoyed a comfortable and peaceful
existence this region's inhabitants were
killing each other since then the
Balkans have been one of Europe's
poorest regions some people call it the
Bermuda Triangle of economics because
when someone invests here their money
mysteriously disappears probably knew a
country like Albania is a bit like
traveling 50 years in the past other
countries accessor B are growing fairly
fast lately but there are still miles
away from being able to join the
European Union
in Greece which is the best boy in the
classroom is bankrupt and has an
unemployment rate of 21% in other words
this doesn't look like a good country
for doing business right
well dear viewer China thinks it is
China is pouring billions of pounds
worth of investment into Greece and
other Balkan countries to create a new
Silk Road from the Mediterranean into
the heart of the European Union we are
talking about almost twenty billion
dollars this is the same cost as hosting
the Olympic Games and it's all in a
region where nobody else seems to invest
a penny
China is bought a harbor and is now
building brand new railroads that will
connect the Balkans with Budapest in
Hungary and that might end up in Germany
but not only that the Chinese government
is paving the way for private
investments can you imagine
Chinese factories on the outskirts of
Belgrade and Aliexpress logistics center
in the middle of Athens Bob this might
be a reality sooner than you might
expect
for a better understanding if we look at
it relative to their population China is
showing a bigger interest in Greece or
Serbia than it is in Germany so now the
question is why is China so interested
in the Balkans this in the support
corrupt and business unfriendly region
mean what is China trying to achieve
here well today we are going to answer
all of these questions but as usual
before we do let's take a look back at
the history a country for sale in the
year 2010 Greece started their budget
cuts the whole country was bankrupt and
the European Union agreed to bail them
out with money from its wealthiest
members
[Music]
but in exchange the Greek government was
supposed to control their spending since
then Greece has gone through all kinds
of political and financial crises
unemployment simply doesn't stop growing
it's now at more than 20 percent since
poverty is on the rise - for a better
understanding Greek public debt is
almost twice that of their entire gross
domestic product and on top of all of
this Greece seems to be allergic to
business they have rampant corruption
red tape and all kinds of laws that have
created a country with almost no major
companies Brussels demanded that the
governments of Alexis Pross make reforms
and sell their state-owned companies but
there was a big problem here being in
the situation that they were nobody
wanted to buy the Greek government's
property so they simply had to drop
their prices to rock bottom in other
words Greece was and still is in a
desperate situation and now guess who
can smell desperation from miles and
miles away yep that would be China
China's Costco acquires 51% stake in
Greece's Piraeus port with this deal
China was killing two birds with one
stone on the one hand one of their
companies was buying one of the name
ports in the Mediterranean Sea on the
other the government of Xi Jingping with
his commitments to investing a three
billion more dollars in the country was
buying a political ally inside the EU
and yes yes yes I know what you're now
thinking the Greek president's Alexis
tsipras the European left rock star
the man who would never sell his
principles to an evil rich guy no matter
how much money was put on the table yeah
yeah well we mean that guy loose blocks
use criticism at UN of China's human
rights record Greece has vetoed a
European Union condemnation of China's
human rights record at the UN
infuriating diplomats and rights
organizations who said the move
undermined that use position as a
defender of human rights
but wait just a minute because this is
not only about politics here let's take
a look at it from an economic
perspective now a Chinese company
controls one of the biggest ports in
Europe
this means Chinese businesses will find
it easier than ever to load their
products into one of the wealthiest
markets on the planet Europe but still
there's a little problem here from the
Piraeus port to Berlin we have more than
2,300 kilometers of distance and on the
way we have poor countries with poor
roads and poor railways but hold on just
a second it because China has already
thought of this remember the one belt
one road projects this is a brand new
Silk Road Xi Jingping
wants to create this is a network of
infrastructure that is meant to connect
the entire world and in Europe this Silk
Road will go through the Balkans
Belgrade Budapest railway construction
starts at the same time Chinese
consulting companies are working to
renovate the railroads between Greece
and Macedonia the goal is to be able to
have one shipment landing in Piraeus and
crossing the whole Balkan Peninsula at a
hundred and sixty kilometers an hour and
all of this is cheaper to build here
than in Italy I mean think about it the
Balkans of cheap land and cheap salaries
and their governments are welcoming this
Chinese money with open arms as we said
at the beginning the Balkans still feel
a bit like the aftermath of the wars
from the 90s the city like Belgrade you
can still see the ruins from the NATO
bombings in 1999 a country like
Montenegro doesn't even have a railroad
that connects it with Bosnia Croatia
despite sharing a border don't forget
that
except for Greece and Croatia none of
these countries are EU members this
means that they hardly get any Brussels
money to rebuild like these Chinese
loans simply like dollars from heaven we
speak about this with European countries
they say why China because they have the
money to be honest
Tirana Xenia Lubitsch Serbian Minister
of Transportation but hold on just a
second here because this is not the end
of the story
what if China wants to go even further
[Music]
Chinese factories in Europe we all know
it China started growing thanks to the
foreign companies that set up in these
special economic zones but the truth is
the real appeal of China during the 90s
was the lower wages however things
they've now changed take a look at this
chart today the average salary in a city
like Shanghai is always the same as that
in Greece and almost double that of the
Serbian salary this means for a Chinese
company Serbia is something close to
what Shenzhen used to be for an American
there's also the fact that Serbian
education is relatively good and they're
close to Germany in summary cheap labor
well educated population and close to
one of the world's most appealing
markets this dear viewer is an
unexplored paradise China's hub a signs
agreement to by Serbian steel plant of
course this news is from 2016 and we
still don't have that many examples but
there are enough cases to show a clear
trends Chinese companies want to start
manufacturing things in Europe and the
Balkans are the perfect place to do that
most specifically they're looking at
Serbia this explains why this year Xi
Jingping himself paid a visit to
Belgrade or why Huawei has already
invested a fortune to improve
telecommunications in the country last
year that's 2017 the Bank of China opens
their first Serbian offices so in a way
we could say that the relationship
between these two countries really
couldn't be any better right now
but I can probably guess what you're
thinking right now I mean very rarely a
visual politic do we tell you that
corruption is a friend of foreign
investments and when it comes to
corruption Serbia certainly starts to
look less like a paradise but make no
mistake Chinese companies are experts in
dealing with this in fact Chinese
businessmen are quite comfortable in
hostile environments they have
demonstrated this when they built those
textile factories in Ethiopia and let's
be honest here China itself isn't
exactly a haven of transparency and
democracy either
[Music]
meanwhile as soon as investment came to
the Balkans the region's fondness for
Europe started going down in 2012 70% of
Serbs want to join the European Union
some people were even willing to change
their alphabet to do that as you
probably know Serbian is a Slavic
language and it's written in Cyrillic
characters some intellectuals wanted to
change it to a Latin alphabet the same
way the Croatians did but now
well this love of Europe it's dropped to
35% at the end of the day with money
flowing into China well he really wants
Brussels funding in past presidential
elections none of the main candidates
talked about joining the European Union
nevertheless nobody in Brussels seemed
to be too worried about this
as we said only China has been capable
of finding business opportunities in
this part of the world the rest of
Europe still sees this as a political
and economic desert the same happens in
many parts of Africa when nobody dared
to invest but all of a sudden Beijing
money came in and now some of these
countries are growing like there's no
tomorrow
so the question is now will we see an
awakening in the Balkans the same way
we've seen it in some African countries
I mean could Greece sir the and perhaps
even Bosnia become a brand new
industrial cluster for Chinese companies
well let us know what you think in the
comments section below and meanwhile if
you want to know more about why
Australia fears China please do click on
this video and also don't forget to
visit the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
are not mine also don't forget brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday so hit
that subscribe button below and as
always thank you for watching and if you
want to learn more about politics and
hear even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider media we have
a podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there
[Music]